in the last video I started with this
matrix right here and we all right from
the get-go we said oh the span of this
matrix is just the span of the column
vectors of it and I just wrote it right
there but we weren't clear whether this
was linearly independent and if it's not
linearly independent it won't be a
sufficient basis and then we go off and
we figure out the null space of a we
find out that the null space of a
contains more than just the zero vector
it's just a span of these two vectors
here which means that these columns are
not linearly independent we saw that
several videos ago and we use that
information that they're not linearly
independent to try to make them linearly
independent by getting rid of the
redundant one so we were able to get rid
of this guy in this guy because these
were essentially the columns associated
with the free variables and we were able
to do it using this little technique
down here where we were able to we set
one of these equal to zero the other one
equal to negative one and then solve for
the pivot variables and then we set the
other one equal to 0 and the other one
equal to negative one and solve for the
pivot variables and you could imagine
that this is a kind of a generalizable
process you can always if you have a
bunch of free variables you can set all
of them but one to equal zero and then
all the other one and then though that
one that you didn't set to zero set it
to equal negative one and then you can
make you can express it as a sum of the
pivot variables where the pivot
variables are a function of the free
variables so in general in general and
this would be kind of a quick way of
doing it we have to do it more slowly
over here if I have if I have some
matrix a and I want to figure out the
basis for the column space this column
space is just a span of these but if I
wanted a linearly independent basis I
need to figure out some set of these
that are linearly independent what I can
do is put this guy into reduced row
echelon form when I put them in reduced
row echelon form and I did that over
here this is this this is Col this is a
reduced row echelon form of a I can look
at the variables that are associated I
can look at the variables that are
associated with the pivot entries so
this is x1 let me write it this let me
scroll up a little bit this associated
with x1 right when you multiply this
times x1 you
this column times x-1 this column times
x2 this column times x3 this column
times x4 like that when you look at just
regular a when you look at just your
matrix a it's the same thing if you were
to write ax equal to zero this column
would be associated with x1 this column
would be associated with x2 x3 and x4
like that what you can do is you put it
in reduced row echelon form you say
which columns have my pivot entries or
associated with pivot variables say okay
x1 and x2 are associated with pivot
variables and or they are the pivot
variables and they're associated with
these first two columns and so those
first two columns would be a basis for
the column space would be a basis for
the column and how did I get this I
might just you know am I just making up
things on the fly well no it all comes
from it all comes from the reality that
you can always construct a situation
where you the vectors associated with
the free variables you can construct
linear you can make them you can write
them as linear combinations of the
vectors associated with the pivot
variables and we did a special case of
that last time so but a very quick and
dirty way of doing it I don't know if
it's actually dirty is just take your
matrix put it in reduced row echelon
form and you say look this column and
this column are associated with my free
variables therefore this column and this
column must be associated with my free
variables the solution sets are the same
to ax equal to zero or the reduced row
echelon form of a X is equal to zero so
the same so if this common this column
are associated with free variables so
are this column in this column which
means that they can be expressed just by
judiciously selecting your values over
free variables as linear combinations of
the columns associated with the pivot
variables with the pivot entries which
are that column in that column so this
column and this column would be a basis
for a and we see that we see that all
the way down here 1 2 3 & 1 1 4 we did a
lot of work and we got all the way there
and we said this is a basis for the
column space
four right for the columns ban of a now
doing all of that work let's see if we
can actually visualize what the column
space of a looks like I have a strange
feeling feeling I might have said column
spans a couple of times but the column
space what does it look like well
there's a couple of ways to think about
what it looks like one way is we can say
look what this fan this is - that's a
member of r3 that's a vector in r3 and
this is a vector in r3 so we have to if
I you know if we imagine this is let me
draw my X Z and normal norm it's drawn
this is normally Y X and z axes in r3 if
I'm going to represent them as
three-dimensional space then you know
the vector 1 2 3 might look like this
where it's 1 1 2 1 2 3 so we go out 1
down here then up 3 so the vector will
look like that in its standard form
that's that one right there and the
vector 1 1 4 would be 1 1 and go up 4 so
it might look something like this it's
hard to actually draw them very well in
three dimensions but you get the idea
but the column space is the span of
these so all of the linear combinations
of these two guys so all of the linear
combinations that these two guys are
going to create a plane that contains
these two vectors that you can if you
just sum these guys up multiple
combinations you can get any vector up
there if you just add them up you'll get
that vector right there if you add this
guy plus 2 times that you'll get some
vector up here so then if you view them
as position vectors they'll essentially
they'll essentially form a plane in r3
but let's see if we can get the equation
for that plane well how can we do that
well we know that we can figure out the
equation of a plane based on the fact
that a normal vector dotted with any any
let's say that this is some that's not
it's not a right my normal vector like
this the normal vector dotted with any
any position vector specifying a
position on the plane so let me call
that X X - any point on the plane or any
vector position on the plane so I could
do that my
is the vector maybe I'll do the minus
vector one two three has to be equal to
zero and we can use this information to
figure out the equation for this plane
but what is a normal vector how can we
find a normal vector to to this plane so
this would be a vector it's a vector let
me see if I can draw this in a way that
doesn't confuse the issue the plane is
like that the normal vector would come
out like that so how can I create a
normal vector well we learned that you
take the cross product of any two
vectors in r3 and the cross product I've
only defined so far in r3 and I will get
a vector that's normal to both of those
vectors so let's take the cross product
let me say this is a nice way of
thinking about it because really
integrating everything that we've
covered so far so let me define my
normal vector to be equal to 1 2 3 cross
1 1 4 and what is this equal what does
this equal so my first term I ignore
that I get 2 times 4 minus 3 times 1 2
times 4 is 8 2 times 4 minus 3 times 1 8
minus 3 then from my second row I have 1
times 4 and my temptation is do 1 times
4 minus 3 times 1
but you reverse it you do 3 times 1 so
it's 3 minus 1 times 4 minus 4 right
we've done that multiple times you might
want to review the cross product video
if that made you if that seemed strange
you ignore the middle row and you say
you normally do 1 times 4 minus 3 times
1 but the middle row you switch or you
keep switching as you go that well
really defining it for r3 so instead we
do 3 times 1 minus 1 times 4 and then
finally for the last row we ignore it we
say 1 times 1 which is 1 minus 2 times 1
which is minus 2 and this is equal to
the vector 5 minus 1 minus 1 which by
definition of the cross product I've
shown this to you multiple times is
normal is normal to both of these
vectors and so they'll be it'll be
normal to any linear combination of
these two vectors so now that we have
our normal vector we can define
think we can define our or we can figure
out the traditional equation for the
plane so we now know that our normal
vector 5 minus 1 minus 1 that I got just
by cross-product taking the cross
product of the our basis vectors dot any
vector in our plane so let me just write
any vector let me try it at X Y Z so X Y
Z since that's how I define my axes up
here is this was the x axis XY and Z X Y
Z - I just picked one of these I could
have picked either of them - 1 2 3 has
got to be equal to 0 so what's this this
is going to be equal to let me write a
little smaller little neater 5 - 1 minus
1 minus 1 dot what's this guy going to
be X minus 1 y -2 and Z minus 3 has got
to be equal to 0 and what's the dot
product it's 5 times X minus 1 5 times X
minus 1 plus or maybe I should say minus
1 so it's plus minus 1 times y minus 2
plus minus 1 times Z minus 3 is equal to
0 that's just the definition of our dot
product and if I simplify this I get 5x
minus 5 minus y minus y plus 2 minus Z
plus 3 is equal to 0 you have two plus
three is five minus five so those all
cancel out those will equal 0 and we get
and we get five X minus y minus Z is
equal to zero and this is our this plane
in r3 is the column space of a so we've
now shown you that it's truly a plane in
a and actually makes 0 it makes sense
that that this plane intersects the
origin right this plane intersects the
origin if you said XY & z equals 0 it
satisfies this equation and that makes
sense because we said that a column
space
matrix has to be a valid subspace and a
valid subspace has to contain the zero
vector and in r3 that's the coordinate
zero zero zero now what I want to do now
is see if we can get at the same answer
if I can get it the same answer going a
completely different way about the
column so or approaching it in a
completely different way so let me get
my original let me get my original a
which I've forgotten and I've marked it
up a good bit but let me just copy and
paste it so that's my original a right
there that's my original a let me copy
it let me paste it nope
that's not what I wanted to do do see so
my original a copied and pasted the
wrong thing let me do it a little want
to waste your time edit copy edit paste
there you go and let me scroll this down
get to a point that's relatively clean
bring my a down where I've used a lot of
space so here you go this is my original
a right there my original a and what I
want to do if I can see if I can get
this result completely different I got
this result by figuring out the basis of
the columns band finding a normal vector
by taking the cross product of our two
basis vectors cross and then using the
dot product of the normal vector with
the difference this vector right here
where you take any normal any vector on
our plane minus one of our basis vectors
that's to find some vector in the plane
this is some vector in the plane so any
vector in the plane dotted with my
normal vector is going to be equal to
zero and actually I should probably make
a side note here that the only reason I
was able to say that the normal vector
is the cross product of my two basis
vectors is because I knew that these two
basis vectors not only do they specify
some point on the plane so let's say
that this guy right here is this blue
vector not only does he specify some
point on the plane right there now does
he specify
this point right there but the vector
lies completely on the plane how did I
know that because and I you know I knew
from the get-go that the zero of zero
vector is in my span right I knew that I
knew that if I draw this guy in just
standard position the point zero zero
zero is on the is in D is in my span and
I know that it's endpoint is in the span
so this whole vector has to be in my
plane and likewise this whole vector has
to be in my plane so if I take the
cross-product anything normal to these
guys or any combination of these guys is
going to be normal to the plane we got
this result right here but let me take
this right here and use our other
definition of column span our other
definition or it's really an equivalent
definition is all of the solutions to
all of the valid solutions to ax let me
write it this way it's all of the valid
solutions to ax where X is a member of
where X is a member of RN or another way
we could think of it is we could view it
as all of the all of the valid B's where
ax is equal to B and let me write this
and maybe I should write an and X is a
member of RN these are equivalent
statements I'm just defining be here to
be ax so this is these are equivalent
statements but let's let's run with this
a little bit so let's say that I define
my B so B is going to be a vector in r3
alright we've already you know we
already have an intuition like that so
let's say that my B let's say that mice
when I pick ax I get a B that's equal to
X Y Z and I want to figure out what X YS
and Z's can I get valid solutions for so
if I take my vector a so let me take my
vector a right there and then let me
multiply it let me multiply it times let
me multiply it times well actually the
best way to do it if I'm just solving
for if I'm just instead of going through
I think we're used to it right now if
I'm solving the equation a
is equal to be sorry is equal to be I
can essentially just create the
Augmented matrix where I have the matrix
a and I can augment it with B and put
this in reduced row echelon form and
that will essentially represent the
solution set so let me do that so if I
just augment this matrix right here
with B so I write X Y Z so this is an
Augmented with B this is a this is B let
me put this in reduced row echelon form
and find the solution set so if I so and
this is just my all the the my this
these are the XY z-- and Z is to define
a valid B so what do I get so if I the
first thing I want to do and we've done
this exercise before
let's keep my first row the same 1 1 1 1
and I get an X and let's replace our
second row with the second row minus the
first row with the second row minus the
first row or let me say the second row
minus 2 times the actually let me do it
this way to let me replace the second
row with 2 times the first row minus the
second row so 2 times the first row
minus the second row we're going to get
a 2x minus y up there and then 2 times 1
minus 2 is 0 2 times 1 minus 1 is 1 2
times 1 minus 4 is minus 2 2 times 1
minus 3 is minus 1 right minus 2 minus 1
fair enough and now let me replace my
third row let me replace my third row
with the third row minus 3 times the
first row so we're going to do the third
let me the third row minus now let me do
it this way
it's the third row the third row minus 3
times the first row so I'm just doing
the B column first because if I can
remember what I did the third row minus
3 times the first row 3 minus 3 times 1
is 0 4 minus 3 times 1 is 1 1 minus 3
times
1 is minus 2 and then 2 minus 3 times 1
2 minus 3 times 1 is minus 1 now I could
go all the way to reduced row echelon
form but something interesting is
already happening so let me let me just
just from the get-go let me try to zero
out this third row and the best way to
zero out this third row is to just
replace the third row so the first row
well I won't even write the first row
the second row is 1 0 1 minus 2 minus 1
and 2x minus y I'm not going to worry
about the first row right now but let's
replace the third row just in our
attempt to go into reduced row echelon
form let's replace it with the second
row minus the third row so you get 2x
minus y minus Z plus 3x right I just
took this minus this so minus Z plus 3x
so what 0 minus 0 is 0 1 minus 1 is 0
minus 2 minus minus 2 is 0 and that's
also 0 so this is we're only going to
have a valid solution we're only going
to have a valid solution to ax equals B
if this guy right here if this guy right
here is equal to 0 what happens if he's
not equal to 0 then we're going to have
0 a bunch of zeros equaling some number
which tells us that there's no solution
so if I pick a B where this guy does not
equal 0 then I'll have no solution if
this guy equals 5 if I pick X wise and
Z's such that this expression is equal
to 5 then ax equal B will have no
solution because I left 0 is equal to 5
so this has to equal 0 so 2x minus y
minus Z plus 3x must be equal to 0 in
order for B to be valid in order for B
to be in to be a member of the column
space of a in order for it to be a valid
vector that the ax can become or the
product a times X can become for some X
so what is this equal
if we add the 2x plus the 3x I get I get
5x 5x minus y minus Z is equal to 0
which is the exact same outcome we got
when we figured out the basis vectors we
said oh you know what the basis vectors
they have to be in the column space
themselves by definition so let me take
let me find a normal vector to them both
by taking the cross product I did that
and I say the cross product times any
valid vector in our in our space minus 1
of the basis vectors has to be equal to
0 and then I got this equation or we
could on the other way we could have
actually literally solved this equation
setting RB equal to this and he said
what B's will give us a valid solution
and our only valid solution will be
obtained when this guy has to be equal
to 0 because the rest of his row became
0 and we set that equal to 0 we got the
exact same equation so hopefully you
found this to be mildly satisfying
because we were able to tackle the same
problem from two different directions
and get the same result and it kind of
shows you the beauty of linear algebra
how it all starts to fit together